hi everyone what's up I'm Alana and
welcome to my channel today I'm going to
be talking to you guys about the new 3ds
for those who aren't familiar with the
new 3ds it's not a brand new 3ds it is a
new 3ds console that they just
confusingly named new 3ds so I thought I
just need very vague first impressions
and basically tell you guys some of the
major changes and what I think it's in
so first things first let's just compare
it to a previous in size this is bigger
but not by much as you can see it is
bigger on both sides it's also a tiny
bit wider so definitely a larger device
then the regular 3ds then if we open
them up for the size difference
something that I find pretty amazing is
how much bigger the screen actually is
cuz I can't actually see what's going on
in the camera right now I assume that
you guys probably getting like a
reflection of my backyard or something
right now so with you but both screens
are significantly bigger than the 3ds
the back has two extra bumpers Ziya and
ZL and the actual game cartridge now
goes in the front there instead of in
the back and the power button is just
there before we get to the internal
stuff another external thing that has
changed which i think is really cool is
face plates so this base plate here
snaps off I mean that doesn't sound that
exciting when you see this like a serial
number and Nintendo underneath there but
of course they will bring out face
plates so you can like mix and match
whenever you want the back one comes off
as well with their screws there so I'm
not gonna show you that but it's
basically exactly the same so then you
just snap it right back in as if it was
a brand new one and it's really simple
today so I'm kind of hoping with the
faceplates thing instead of needing to
release special edition or limited
edition consoles I'll have special
edition or limited edition faceplate so
you don't have to buy a whole new
console you can just collect all the
faceplates which is really cool for the
inside the first and probably most
obvious thing is that these bad boys are
now colored I just have so many issues
with X being at the top and also being
blue Microsoft Sony and Nintendo all
have blue X's in different positions why
are you doing this doing it there's also
an extra little thing next to the camera
there and I'm fairly sure that that is
like a motion tracking thing for your
face when I say I'm not sure I mean that
I don't know if it's that actual thing
that does it I mean that it definitely
does have facial tracking so point that
isn't when you have the 3d on you can
kind of move it around
and it's synced to your face so even if
it's like on an angle or away from you
you don't need to sort of you like move
it around and squint at it to get it to
work it kind of just moves to you I
usually play on the 3ds XL and I very
rarely use the 3d function unless I'm
kind of doing it just for like a
gimmicky thing where I'm like huh look
how pretty it is oh let's turn that off
and I find it that's because sometimes
it's a little difficult to align it kind
of hurts after a while you have to
concentrate a lot with the new 3d yes I
can use 3d and kind of forget that I'm
using it but the biggest hardware change
and why I feel like they even brought
the new console out in the first place
is that thing that is basically a new
toggle it doesn't look like one and it
doesn't feel like one but that's how it
functions it's something that you kind
of nudge or wipe your thumb over to
control the camera now I don't have any
games that have the cam control yet but
there will be a handful of new 3ds
exclusives so there will be games that
will let you control that camera so I'm
gonna do my best to show you guys the
new thumbstick in action if I can try
and record that it's really hard to
record DS gameplay I'll write it to that
I just wanted to talk about my only
complaint it feels like if I pushed hard
enough I could just pull it out of that
socket and it also feels like if I use
it enough that the outside edges are
going to sort of become soft instead of
that hard suckle then they're going to
like fade it into a shape I feel like
they probably would have been reports of
it falling apart out of Japan by now I
thought we're going to happen so maybe
it's not but I am interested to see how
it goes because that's that's just the
material it feels like it's not solid so
I'm not gonna do my best to show it to
you guys in action so this is Kid Icarus
and I will be showing you guys right now
so unfortunately I can't move the camera
in this one but it is a game that's
compatible with Circle Pad Pro so I am
controlling the character with it right
now if you guys can tell I'm kind of
just colliding my thumb over it where if
I use this you know it's kind of a
frantic you can actually push it you can
hear it you couldn't do that with that
it's it's almost like it's a little a
little touchscreen patent kind of thing
in that you just it just sort of follows
your thumb around
yeah when the consoles were first
announced I thought that it was kind of
crappy that they were bringing out a new
console so soon after the - yes very
example because it's basically like
making them completely redundant so
although the three is better it has a
faster CPU there's some upgrades to the
internet software so there's some basic
upgrades there I don't think that this
console was intended to replace the 3ds
and 3ds I think that's supposed to be
catered towards more hardcore DS games
games that you play for a really long
time super long RPGs that need those
camera controls it's like opening it up
to those for 100 hour games I'm Ilana
this is the new 3ds not to the excel
this is just the regular one and
obviously I don't have any fancy
faceplates just yet I hope you guys
enjoyed this quick first impression
slash demo video I'm alone thank you
guys for watching and I'll see you next
time bye